[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance Trump's lawyers reportedly
believe Robert Muller could issue a
public declaration of Trump's innocence
Muller evidently feels so differently
about this that he reportedly has had
one of his lawyers searching to
determine the limits of Trump's ability
to issue pardons that the Trump Russia
scandals are so momentous and so
unprecedented should be obvious to
anyone paying the slightest attention
that they are perceived so utterly
differently by the prosecutor and the
possible defendant just as obviously
implies that one side is led by a man
who is completely out of his mind see if
you can guess which president Trump's
lawyers are / Matt Apuzzo and my friend
Michael Schmidt of the New York Times
cooperating with the special counsel in
the hope that mr. Muller will declare in
the coming months that mr. Trump is not
a target of the Russia inquiry
cooperating evidently means producing
the documents the special counsel wants
the public declaration of innocence
evidently means Trump's lead attorney Ty
Cobb and the other attorneys evidently
believe their client rather than the
mounting evidence mounting evidence in
just the last several weeks new angles
to the collusion conspiracy have
sprouted and others have been freshly
reinvigorated for instance we have
learned something about Natalya vessel
myths kaya the Russian lawyer who met
with Trump jr. Paul Manafort and Jared
Kushner in Trump Tower in June 2016 a
meeting the subject of which produced a
cover-up reportedly led by this
presidential impostor from onboard air
force one vessel mitts kya had met two
months earlier it turns out in Moscow
with the pro-russian california
congressman dana rohrabacher and we have
learned that Rohrabacher says he has
been kept from talking to trump about
making a deal for Julian Assange a trade
of evidence supposedly possessed by
Assange that would exonerate Russia from
having interfered in the 2016 election
in exchange for a pardon for Assange and
he says the primary person who has done
this is White House chief of staff John
Kelly we have learned that bezel mid
Skye herself
the other Russians who joined her at the
Trump Tower meeting signed
non-disclosure agreements about those
meetings we have learned that Muller's
investigation now reportedly includes
Michael G Flynn son of the former
national security advisor General
Michael Flynn focusing quote at least in
part on his work with his father's
lobbying firm Flynn Intel group we have
learned that a member of the Russian
parliament [ __ ] slovnik on/off went
on national television there and
insisted quote US intelligence missed it
that Russian intelligence stole the
president of the United States we have
learned that another Russian politician
a far-right leader named Nikita s I EV
said on state television there that his
country's government should quote hit
Donald Trump with our compromise and
when asked if Russia really has such
blackmail material answered quote of
course we have it and we have learned
that many in the intelligence community
have reportedly warmed up to the good
old Steel dossier as 128 years CIA man
who retired as a member of the
leadership team that guides the agency's
global activities wrote in retrospect
there is even some indication that the
salacious sexual allegations should not
be dismissed out of hand and he
concludes that we quoting again will
have to do our best to validate the
information at hand looking at new
information through the framework
outlined in the steel document is not a
bad place to start and the BBC world
affairs reporter I often quote here Paul
wood seems to have almost deliberately
buried these stunning words 12
paragraphs deep in his most recent piece
for the British magazine The Spectator
quoting the president bizarrely asserted
that the steel dossier had been paid for
by Russia in order to damage him this is
the latest twist in Trump's response to
the dossier which began with flat
denials in January that he had been
filmed by Russian intelligence with
prostitutes in a Moscow hotel room that
remains unproven nevertheless Steele is
not the only source
I heard of Russian compliment
compromising material on Trump from two
sources months before the steel dossier
came to light
there are reports of witnesses in the
hotel who corroborate Steele's reporting
these include an American who said to
have seen a row with hotel security over
whether the alleged hookers would be
allowed up to Trump suite now claims are
circulating of more tapes showing even
more extreme behavior expect these
allegations to emerge in due course and
most importantly we have learned that
Muller's team reportedly interviewed the
author of that dossier the British X
intelligence officer Christopher Steele
sometime over the summer
perhaps more important still we learned
that Muller's operation is so
disciplined and forgive the phrase leak
free that the interview of Steele in the
summer was not known until the autumn
that's why the only other bit of news
coming from inside Muller's
investigation is so extraordinary as
Bloomberg News reported acting as
Muller's top legal counsel
Michael Dreeben has been researching
past pardons and determining what if any
limits exist
Business Insider dot-com tried to
explain this like the president
governor's also have the authority to
grant pardons and Renato Mariotti a
former federal prosecutor told Business
Insider that it was possible Dreeben was
looking into state-level case law going
back to the country's early years to
find instances in which a court found a
governor's pardon problematic dreeben's
probably spending all day researching
those cases and he's probably going to
find some analogy that Muller can use in
case Trump issues a pre-emptive pardon
or one that stymies the investigation
Mariotti said translation Muller's got a
guy looking into how he can stop Trump
from pardoning his own family staff
aides cabinet members lawyers himself
perhaps even before they're actually
charged with anything yeah that all
sounds like Trump should be expecting a
clean bill of health from Robert Muller
any day now you don't have to be a law
professor to realize this is not a
hypothetical Muller is not writing a
research paper
if Muller is trying to find out if he
can legally challenge Trump's
presidential pardons it obviously means
Muller is in theory prepared to try to
legally challenge Trump's presidential
pardons it obviously means Muller
is readying himself for time in the
not-too-distant future where Trump will
determine he's in so much trouble he's
going to have to start issuing
presidential pardons resist remove peace
the book based on these commentaries
hits the streets next Tuesday please
enjoy buy it or borrow a copy at least